würdest du eher 20 Millionen Youtube
abonnenten haben wollen oder einen
Blockbuster Action Film produzieren gibt
mir die Abos könnt ihr auch mal direkt
machen klicken wir also auf die 20
Millionen guck mal wir sind klar in der
Mehrheit also ist ja auch safe lieber
einen intelligenten Partner haben oder
einen gut aussehenden Partner
boah in der Beziehung müssen alle
Parameter irgendwie stimmen so dass man
komplett glücklich ist und es gibt ja
auch dieses Standard Zitat Aussehen
zieht an Charakter hält fest und das
stimmt ja auch aber wenn ich wüsste ich
müsste langfristig mit einer Person
zusammen sein dann definitiv Intelligenz
sind wir auch in der Mehrheit das ist
das attraktivste was es gibt diese
Fragen sind so stark lieber einen Hund
haben wollen der sich wie eine Katze
verhält oder eine Katze haben die sich
wie ein Hund verhält das ist so
schwer oh ich finde das Verhalten von
ein Hund halt deutlich cooler deswegen
würde ich wirklich eher eine Katze haben
die sich wie ein Hund verhält ja S auch
no mehr Halt bisher s wir so richtig
Standardantwort machen lieber zweimal im
Jahr Weihnachten feiern oder zweimal im
Jahr den Geburtstag oh mein Gott ich
glaube ich würde lieber zweimal im Jahr
Weihnachten ja die Frage ist mit dem
Geburtstag wird man dann auch doppelt so
schnell alt quasi oder ist man einfach
der einzige Mensch der zweimal im Jahr
Geburtstag hat weil das wäre ein
bisschen weird dann würde ich eher sagen
lass ein Fest für alle nehmen und zwar
Weihnachten ja e wir bei jeder Frage in
der Mehrheit würden wir lieber für
Google oder für Apple Arbeiten digcker
ich schwöre euch ich liebe diese App ich
weiß nicht warum ich diese Videos so
alle paar Monate mache aber das ist so
interessant beide Unternehmen sind
natürlich krass einige der größten
Unternehmen der Welt sehr Technologie
versiert sehr modern haben Geisteskranke
Arbeitsbedingungen so oder so würde ich
mich glaube ich trotzdem für Apple
entscheiden ja S auch Mehrheit Apple
wirkt irgendwie cooler lieber
Sommerkleidung im Winter tragen oder
Winterkleidung im Sommer ey es ist
wirklich ich will es nicht zu oft loben
aber das ist richtig geil ich liebe
solche Videos wenn wir mit
Sommerkleidung im Winter rumlaufen ist
uns dauerhaft kalt und wir werden
wahrscheinlich die ganze Zeit krank wenn
wir allerdings mit Winterkleidung im
Sommer rumlaufen ist uns immer zu heiß
wir schwitzen die ganze Zeit und alle
denken wir sind dumm ich würde trotzdem
zweites
nehmen das verstehe ich nicht wir werden
ja die ganze Zeit krank beim ersten beim
zweiten ja nicht und ich finde so
Wintersachen kann man immer besser
rocken als so Somm Saen also kann man
immer geiler kombinieren mit irgendwie
Overlays und so Tag Leute Luca hier aus
dem Schnitt ich hatte ab diesem
Zeitpunkt keine Aufnahme mehr von meinem
iPad habe mir allerdings überlegt da ich
noch weiß was das für Fragen war und das
ja auch kommentiert habe dass ich
einfach ein Screenshot mache und das
drauf schreibe für euch verändert sich
nicht viel ich habe im Schitt allerdings
eine Menge Arbeit habe ich lieb das war
gelogen würden wir lieber fliegen wollen
wie Superman also so Zack und dann
fliegen wir so durch die Welt rum oder
reisen wie Spider-Man also Spider-Man
kann ja quasi auch fliegen in ein
Gewissen Form der sprüht dann halt seine
komischen Fäden dar raus und fliegt von
Hochaus zu Hochaus die Sache ist ganz
eindeutig Spider-Man braucht immer
irgendwas wo er seinen schei da dran
festmachen kann deswegen safe Superman
ganz klassisch in der Mehrheit lieber
ein Leben lang kostenlos Filme haben
oder ein Lebenlang kostenloses
Mittagessen sag mal seid ihr am
Arsch Mittagessen ist ein Grundbedürfnis
ohne Mittagessen können wir nicht
überleben natürlich will ich erstmal
meine ganzen Grundbedürfnisse decken
lieber eine Million Dollar jetzt
bekommen oder mit dem Wissen dass du
jetzt hast 5 Jahre
zurückgeben seid ihr
dumm die würden eher jetzt Million
nehmen diger gib mir lass mich nur einen
Tag zurück gehen nur zack 24 Stunden
zurück mit meinem jetzigen Wissen von
heute ich mache dir 40 Millionen wollen
wir lieber für immer ein gebrochenes
Herz haben oder niemals geliebt
werden
erstes die Mehrheit lieber jeden Tag nur
eine Farbe tragen dürfen oder jeden Tag
sieben Farben tragen müssen ich meine
jetzt mal ganz dumm betrachtet ich habe
gerade an mir allein an den Socken weiß
schwarz also schon zwei Farben dann habe
ich noch eine schwarze Hose ein weißes
Shirt und verdammt ich habe gerade nur
zwei Farben ich dachte ich hätte mehr
ähm ja jeden Tag sieben was sind wir
auch in der Minderheit trag halt einfach
eine Unterhose die eh keiner sieht mit
sieben verschiedenen Farben als ob ich
den ganzen Tag dann mal nur ein schwarz
oder nur ein weiß rumlauf paar Sachen
ergeben mir gar keinen Sinn wären wir
lieber ein großartiger Koch oder hätten
einen persönlichen Chefkoch
zweitens also ich I know Meinungen sind
verschieden und klar wir können nicht
immer in der Mehrheit sein aber bei
solchen Sachen man kann doch alles
sinnvoll widerlegen hier guck mal ja
okay großartig kochen können super aber
wenn du ein Chefkoch hast obviously die
ganze Zeit dann hast du damit gar keinen
Stress kannst dich einfach bekochen
lassen und ich habe ja eh die Ansicht
hallo
warum ist mein stugart weit nach hinten
gegangen brauchst keine Skills um kochen
zu können diger du musst einfach nur ein
Rezept befolgen können wären wir lieber
gern halb so groß wie jetzt oder doppelt
so schwer wie jetzt halb so groß wären
bei mir ich bin
194 das wären
cm die ich groß wä also knapp 1
Meter wenn ich doppelt so schwer wäre
wie jetzt ich wiege gerade knapp 90 dann
wäre ich bei 180 es ist natürlich beides
jetzt nicht so super ich würde aber eher
sagen doppelt so
schwer das kann man ja dann
ändern wenn du sagst zack so dann dann
kann ich ja wieder von von mein 180 kg
dann mache ich ein jah Diät dann bin ich
ja wieder bei mein 90 kg ich verstehe
ein paar Ansichten hier nicht würden wir
lieber unser Einkommen verdoppeln können
also in meinem Fall dann quasi 20
Millionen Euro monatlich halt de ma oder
unsere Ausgaben halbieren ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich würde eher mein Einkommen
verdoppeln wollen
weil niemand hat Einkommen gleich
Ausgaben oder wenn man es hat dann
kalkuliert man halt ziemlich dumm und
ist finanzwirtschaftlich gesehen
ziemlich auf den Kopf gefallen aber uh
oh oh der ist gut der ist
gut nein lieber Höhenangst haben oder
Angst vor Wasser hei dann wasserangst
ich weiß es nicht Höhenangst oder Angst
vor Wasser ich glaube dann doch eher die
Höhenangst mal auch kleiner Mehrheit
weil Angst vor Wasser das wird ja dann
auch so Zähne putzen
Wasser Hilfe oh Duschen auch
nee es ist manchmal so blöd lieber immer
Schlamm im Schuh haben oder immer ein
Kieselstein im Schuh ey es sind so dumme
Fragen teilweise bzw so dumme
Gegenüberstellungen aber trotzdem das
ist eine ganz also es ist auch eine voll
gute Frage das ist so
ah Schlamm ist
so ist die ganze Zeit eklig du muss die
ganze Zeit deine Socken waschen aber
Kieselstein drückt so eklig deswegen ich
glaube ich glaube ich würde doch den
Kieselstein nehmen sind auch mit in der
Mehrheit wen man den immer so ein
bisschen so nach nach vorne kicken kann
aber das ist ja auch so dumm du weißt
immer wenn du ein Schuh anziehst da ist
jetzt ein Stein drin aber schreibt ihr
mir doch mal gern unten in die
Kommentare ob ihr lieber dauerhaften
Kieselstein oder dauerhaft Schlamm im
Schuh haben wollt lasst ein Daumen hoch
unter dem Video hier da wenn es euch
gefallen hat abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke um weitere Videos
nicht zu verpassen wir sehen uns morgen
neuen Video wieder rein tschüss ist so
peinig das kannst du so nicht machen
nein das machen wir neu